ccôte avec eux toutes ces années
enen Afghanistan.
MeMerci beaucoup Yasmine.
AvAvec nous en direct Monsieur
GaGarneau.
- - Bonsoir Monsieur Roy.
OnOn a le bilan canadien. 3700
pepersonnes ont pu gagner le pa.
AvAvez-vous l'autre chiffre est
plplus difficile c'est-à-dire ce
ququ'on a laissé derrière?
- - On n'a pas de chiffres exacs
papar ce que il faut qu'un citon
ququi va en Afghanistan soit
enenregistré et ce n'est pas
ququelque chose qui est
obobligatoire. Ce n'est pas les
chchiffres exacts et également l
y y a des Canadiens et des
cicitoyens permanents qui aurait
pupu aller dans un pays limitroe
etet d'autres Canadiens qui
auauraient pu embarquer sur des
vovols des alliés et alors on na
papas les chiffres exacts on sat
ququ'il y en a c'est sûr. Le pls
grgrand chiffre, c'est un traval
dede plus longue haleine qui vae
fafaire dans le courant de la
prprochaine année.
- - Monsieur Garneau, vous avez
cocomme moi entendu vous lisais
dadans les journées vous voyaisà
lala télévision, des gens qui
didisent : peut-être dans les
dederniers 10 jours on ne pouvat
papas le faire plusm, tout le
momonde était confronté au même
chchaos mais depuis le mois de
féfévrier dernier quand Monsieur
BiBiden a dit on part pourquoi
esest-ce que ce rapatriement n'a
papas été fait plus rapidement?
- - C'est parce que nous avons
totous été surpris de la rapidié
avavec laquelle les talibans se
sosont emparés du pays.
LaLa très très faible résistance
dede la part de l'armée afghane
nanationale. Tout le monde a été
prpris au dépourvu et les choses
sosont faites très très
rarapidement.
- - Vous ne reconnaissez pas a
poposteriori qu'on aurait pu alr
plplus vite depuis six ou sept
momois pour rapatrier ces gens i
popotentiellement étaient en
dadanger?
- - C'est toujours facile de
reregarder par en arrière et de
didire qu'on aurait dû commencer
plplus rapidement, mais je peux
vovous dire qu'on avait planifié
lala sortie sauf que, les
évévénements se sont bousculés
trtrès très rapidement. Et voil.
OnOn est dans la situation qui
exexiste en ce moment. Je veux
réréitérer que le Canada s'engae
fefermement à sortir tous ceux i
sosont des citoyens canadiens et
dedes résidents permanents et ds
AfAfghans vulnérables tels qu'on
l'l'a promis et qu'on met en ple
totoutes les mesures nécessaires
popour accomplir cette tâche.
- - Combien il y avait des
pepersonnels canadiens depuis dx
sesemaines à Kaboul?
- - Il y avait environ 70
mimilitaires et j'écoutais
l'l'entrevue juste il y a deux
miminutes, des militaires des
foforces spéciales sont sortis e
l'l'enceinte de l'aéroport pour
reretrouver des candidats
cacanadiens éligibles pour les
vovols canadiens.
IlIl y avait également quelque
ememployé de mon émissaire, issu
dudu ministère de l'immigration
popour s'occuper de ces gens.
C'C'était pour les mettre sur ds
avavions.
- - On a fermé l'ambassade comme
plplusieurs autres pays Monsieur
GaGarneau, mais nous,
cocontrairement aux Britanniques
etet aux Français d'autres, on a
papas laissé sur place un patroà
l'l'aéroport de Kaboul dans une
amambassade d'urgence, on est
rerevenu au pays. Est-ce que ça
n'n'aurait pas été sur place avt
lele capitaine pour coordonner
enentre l'immigration et
mimilitaires?
- - On a rapidement ramené les
mimilitaires et les employés du
gogouvernement pour un petit
momoment il y avait personne.
C'C'était basé sur le jugement e
l'l'ambassadeur que je respecte.
C'C'est lui qui est responsableà
momon avis de tout le monde. Il
esest responsable des employés s
mimilitaires. Il a jugé que
c'c'était important de quitter
popour des raisons de sécurité.l
obobligation moi, de p prendre n
coconsidération. C'est ce qu'ona
fafait. On a ramené des gens por
fafaire tout ce qu'on devait fae
popour avoir le maximum de vol.
CoComme vous savez, on a réussià
enen sortir.
- - Monsieur Garneau en termina,
popour les Canadiens et pour les
amamis des Canadiens et les
avavenants qui sont encore là-b,
ilil y aura les voies terrestres
s's'il y a un plan pour tenter
sosoit par l'Ouzbékistan ou le
PaPakistan de faire sortir ces
gegens?
- - Ces gens reconnaissent les
ririsques qu'ils doivent prendre
enen considération dans les
didifférentes options de sortie
papar voie terrestre. Moi ce que
jeje peux vous dire, c'est que s
amambassades seront prêtes à les
acaccueillir s'ils peuvent se
rerendre dans ces pays tiers.
L'L'autre option qui est
imimportante à reconnaître, c'et
prprobablement l'aéroport va
rorouvrir dans les jours à venir
cocomme un aéroport normal. C'et
ququelque chose sur leququel on
trtravaille avec plusieurs pays
avavec les talibans, on a
rerecommandé d'ouvrir l'aéroport
etet ce sera une voie de sortie
papar vol commercial
évéventuellement.
- - Est-ce qu'on négocie ou on
didiscute avec les talibans
acactuellement?
- - Nous avons eu des
cocommunications avec les talibs
papar des intermédiaires au Qatr
etet c'est parce que c'est
nénécessaire de passer certains
memessages. Ça n'a rien à faire
avavec la reconnaissance des
tatalibans. C'est une question e
l'l'importance des panneaux de
cocommunication.
- - Comment qualifiez-vous la
cocommunication entre les talibs
etet le Canada?
- - C'est trop tôt pour le dire.
IlIls ne sont même pas vraiment
cocomplètement organisés. Ils ot
énénormément de travail devant x
popour s'organiserer. C'est sûre
nonous le Canada et le G7 et
d'd'autre groupes multilatérauxn
a a des choses à leur dire parce
quque s'ils veulent continuer...
sisi nous nous voulons continuer
d'd'aider ces pays, on a annoncé
auaujourd'hui 50 millions en aie
huhumanitaire, il va falloir aui
quque les talibans puissent
sasatisfaire à certaines
coconditions si par exemple on
pepermet de l'aide au
dédéveloppement.
CeCertaines de ces conditions et
dede ne pas encourager ou de
pepermettre l'incubation de
grgroupes terroristes qu'elle
ququ'on a vue aujourd'hui.
C'C'est un problème extrêmement
sésérieux et deuxièmement le pls
imimportant, c'est de plus en
rerespect pour les droits humais
paparticulièrement pour les fems
etet les filles.
CeCe sont des conditions sine qa
nonon que nous allons nous mette
dedevant les talibans.